en un plazo de 30 días la aplicación de
tiktok ya debe haber desaparecido de los
teléfonos móviles oficiales un ultimátum
que dio la Casa Blanca a las agencias
federales argumentando que la seguridad
nacional estaba en riesgo un temor a ser
espiado o que se recopilen datos
gubernamentales que también comparten
Canadá la Unión Europea e incluso Taiwán
en donde se tomaron acciones similares
estamos tomando la decisión que para los
equipos del gobierno es mejor que no
accedan a tiktok por las preocupaciones
que tiene la gente en términos de
seguridad
la medida está en línea con nuestras
estrictas políticas internas de
ciberseguridad para el uso de
dispositivos móviles queremos mantener
un alto nivel de conciencia cibernética
en su trabajo diario
pero aunque más de la mitad de los
estados ya le prohibían a sus
funcionarios tener tiktok a nivel
nacional la unión estadounidense de
libertad de civiles acusó la medida como
restrictiva de la libre expresión
mientras que china el país creador de la
aplicación acusó a Washington de abuso
de poder Estatal
qué tan insegura puede estar la
principal superpotencia del mundo para
tener la aplicación favorita de los
jóvenes como esta Estados Unidos ha
estado exagerando el concepto de
seguridad nacional y abusando del poder
Estatal para reprimir a las empresas
extranjeras
la prohibición de tiktok violaría los
derechos de la primera enmienda de
millones de estadounidenses que usan la
aplicación para expresarse a diario by
Dance la casa matriz de tiktok ha dicho
que las preocupaciones acerca de la
seguridad no tienen fundamento y que
nunca ha usado la Aplicación para espiar
estadounidenses pero las dudas de
occidente empezaron a materializarse
desde que se encontraron objetos no
identificados en el espacio aéreo de
Norte centro y Suramérica algo que trajo
el espionaje nuevamente a la Esfera
internacional